ça fait 16 ans qu'il est sur les routes
de France a enchaîné les petits boulots
à gauche à droite mais ça fait depuis 15
mois qu'il a entamé un tour de France à
pied il a une jument tu tu viens ma
belle un chien attention mon ganche une
poule et un bou ferme ta gueule tu l'
appelé ferme ta gueule voilà un petit
clin d'il à camelotte ces animaux vous
formez un clan c'est ça c'est ma famille
c'est mes
enfants non pas bon pour toi pas bon
pour toi ferme ta gueule tu viens allez
allez ouais super c'est très bien mon tu
sais tout faire en fait mais si je fais
pas il faut que j'appelle du monde pour
le faire et donc du coup je paye moi
j'ai aucun revenu fixe pas de RSA pas de
chômage par contre j'ai du temps du
temps pour apprendre du temps pour faire
c'est là qui est ma
[Musique]
richesse